[تصفيق]
جمهوريات فولشانسك هذه إلى رمضان
مسيرة المضيف بقرار من غروزني
حصل مدينة دوما على لقب فخري
مواطن المدينة بالتهديد والمكافأة
ميدالية الذكرى 200 عام لمدينة غروزني
nurmagomedova تتحرك بزاوية هي أنت
بطل مطلق ويوتا
[تصفيق]
مرسوم صادر عن رئيس جمهورية الشيشان ل
مساهمة وتطوير الثقافة البدنية و
تلقى الأنشطة الرياضية
منحت الاعتراف العام باللقب
تكريم عامل الثقافة البدنية
جمهورية الشيشان نورماغوميدوف
abdulmanap في Magomed هؤلاء مستحقين
مدرب روسي
مدرب عربة من المنتخب الوطني للجمهورية
داغستان في قتال سامبو
رئيس جمهورية الشيشان رمضان
احمدوفيتش قديروف السلام عليكم
الإخوة لطيفون حقًا
هكذا دعا أخونا العزيز رمضان
تحدثنا الليلة الماضية ، أخبرته بذلك
سآتي غدا إن شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك
أنني دعيت بعد القتال الذي رأيته
كل هذه الفيديوهات كم شخص لي
هنا دعموا الشيشان الشقيقة
وبالتالي